immer noch bedrohliche infektionszahlen
in europa und den usa viel besser läuft
es gerade ironischerweise in china der
kommenden weltmacht nummer eins wo das
virus woher kommt aber aktuell nicht
mehr viel zu melden hat zumindest wenn
ich mir diese bilder hier angucke
chinesischen klub sind schon wieder
rappelvoll
man feiert halloween paraden mit zombie
krankenschwestern und dass ihr tut
richtig weh
die chinesen haben ein oktoberfest wir
nicht voll ungerecht wir sitzen traurig
zu hause mit einer tüte erdnussflips und
die fortan ihr halbes hendl
beziehungsweise ihr halbes hendl
entschuldigung ich wollte den witz nicht
bringen aber wenn nicht jetzt wann dann
meine damen und herren
möglicherweise kommt so eine diktatur
wie china mit pandemien besser klar als
wir sieht danach aus obendrein haben
chinesische forscher jetzt sogar den
ursprung der solche ausgemacht nix
fledermaus in der ostchinesischen stadt
tianjin hat es einen krone ausbruch
gegeben der angeblich durch eine aus
deutschland importierte schweinshaxe
ausgelöst worden sein soll
ja das klingt mir sehr plausibel
der täter war eine gefrorene achse aus
bremen sie wurde von der chinesischen
polizei verhört und dann erschossen
natürlich hast du es als
überwachungsstaat leichter gegen kuwait
bei denen wird nicht gefragt du magst du
vielleicht die korona app runterladen du
sie wissen sowieso immer wo jeder
chinese gerade ist eigentlich ein
totaler albtraum und trotzdem feiert
peking sich jetzt als das dem westen
total überlegene system sie sagen gehen
nicht raus und dann gehen wir nicht raus
aber in deutschland sagt die regierung
gehe nicht raus und du hörst nicht auf
sie ihr glaubt ihr habt freiheiten das
ist das problem habe ja aber im liften
sind wir top demokratie muss plötzlich
ihre attraktivität beweisen in einer
welt mit zunehmendem hang zur autokratie
und einer immer erfolgreichen
volksrepublik china
ja wenn er bei denen werden ganze
millionenstädte mal eben für monate
abgeriegelt und dann ist da natürlich
noch das sozial
das system da kann präsident an deinem
persönlichen punktestand immer sehen ob
du ein guter oder ein schlechter bürger
bist wer viel alkohol kaufte zeigt
abhängigkeit und verliert punkte eine
packung windeln gibt pluspunkte für
verantwortlichkeit erstens euro zweitens
wenn man richtig viel gesoffen hat sind
windeln tatsächlich sehr verantwortlich
egal der westen wirkt insgesamt muss man
sagen er hilflos angesichts der großen
chinesischen herausforderung diese woche
haben sie auch noch die gründung der
größten freihandelszone der welt
verkündet 15 asiatische länder
handelsvolumen 12,4 billionen wow und
wenn australien oder kanada ist wagen
die chinesen auch nur ein bisschen zu
kritisieren zeit ihre wirtschaft direkt
einen verdammt hohen preis deswegen
verhält sich deutschland auch eher still
ja so können wir uns gar nicht leisten
die chinesen zu ärgern zumal ja auch
militärisch längst eine supermacht sind
den abtrünnigen bruderstaat taiwan will
china zurück wir schließen die anwendung
von gewalt nicht aus glaubt man ihm
direkt china hat in den letzten zehn
jahren 80 prozent mehr für rüstung
ausgegeben dass ein wort aber uns kann
da wenig passieren ich meine das sind
quasi freunde mindestens gute bekannte
die kaufen schließlich weiter deutsche
autos machen immer öfter urlaub in
europa das ist doch schön
ich finds gut und obendrein verbindet
uns neuerdings auch noch das große
seidenstraßen projekt dafür haben die
chinesen unter anderem ganz griechenland
und portugal gekauft schnäppchen 11.000
km transportwege und handelsrouten
kosten etwa 1000 milliarden euro
endpunkt in deutschland soll duisburgs
macht total sinn
duisburg ist bekanntlich der endpunkt
von allem grüße und wir können
wahrscheinlich froh sein wenn uns die
chinesen demnächst noch ihre handys
zusammenbauen lassen wenn sie wenigstens
unser schweinefleisch kaufen an blöde
seidenstraße
das können wir doch auch leute ich meine
wenn wir deutschen was können dann
großer infrastrukturprojekte die angeber
bauen von peking nach duisburg dann
bauen wir unsere globale handelsroute
eben von duisburg nach peking musste
erstmal drauf kommen und die nennen wir
dann achtung schinkenstraße mit
fahrradweg und alle zehn kilometer bauen
wir eine so genannte raststätte kennt
der chinese nicht da kann man für nur 70
cent pipi machen im dass peking alles
unter der aufsicht des besten
verkehrsministers der welt die
schinkenstraße führt von duisburg
richtung ferner osten und dann
überqueren wir die rheinbrücke bei
leverkusen die bestimmt bald fertig
gebaut wird
wen wollen wir forschen wir können dann
sowas nicht und jetzt auch noch die neue
xxl freihandelszone unter chinesischer
führung
dagegen sieht sogar der europäische
binnenmarkt echt alt aus hier bilder vom
letzten eu china gipfel im chinesischen
staats tv alle winken sie dem
chinesischen präsidenten zu und jean
ping allmächtig zumindest ist er der
einzige der redet bei der chinesischen
version des gipfels merkel ursula von
der leyen und eu-ratspräsident michelle
klicken
und schreiben eifrig mit ja sie
schreiben 100 mal
ich werde nie wieder chinas hongkong
politik kritisieren aus aeschi von der
leyen die hat wie immer beraterverträge
unterschrieben so welche chancen hat
unsere eu in konkurrenz zum neuen riesen
asia markt erscheint einmal live nach
brüssel zu unserer reporterin carolin
kebekus caroline können wir da als
demokratien vereint und gemeinsam
bestehen ja klar aber sie wieder bambus
geraucht nein keine chance warum weil
diese so genannte union es nicht mal
schafft in zeiten allerhöchster not
zusammenzuhalten
da beschließt man einen neuen eu
haushalt inklusive dringend benötigter
corona hilfen für italien und spanien
alle atmen kurz auf und dann ungarn und
polen drohen damit dass etwa 1,8
millionen euro schwere finanzpaket zu
blockieren
der grund ist ein geplantes rechtsstaats
instrument dieses sieht bei verstößen
gegen die rechtsstaatlichkeit die
kürzung von eu geldern vor unfassbar
aber an dieser ungarische gulasch mit
ohren liegt ein veto ein
gegen die rechtsstaats klausel und gibt
damit zu dass ungarn kein rechtsstaat
ist der unser in polnischer gangster
kollege erpressen die komplette eu ging
der korona krise da sagt selbst der remo
clan in berlin während er seine
geklauten juwelen zählt alter ihr seid
ja drauf und was macht brüssel jetzt ja
was wohl ein dummes gesicht wie immer
gestern abend beim video gipfel haben
die anderen staatschefs die erpresser
höflich gefragt ob sie nicht vielleicht
aufhören möchten mit dem erpressen
worauf die erpresser gesagt haben
möchten wir eigentlich nicht und dann
haben die anderen gesagt ja schade wenn
ich die märkte wäre ich würde nach
seinem gipfel alpha ausrasten fuß
mitgehen und verlor noch bullen das
waren im großen ganzen heute unsere
diskussion also
sehr interessant interessant
entschuldigung aber interessant ist dass
kolibris rückwärts fliegen oder das
robot code würfelförmige ist das ist
interessant was warschau und budapest
gerade mit der eu machen es einfach nur
zum kotzen
in ungarn werden kritische medien
eingeschüchtert polen schafft
unabhängige gerichte und nebenbei das
recht auf abtreibung ab mitten in der eu
und wenn man den sowas verbieten will
wenn das gesetz wird würde die eu zu
einer sowjetunion natur sowjetunion
wir sagen nein zu diesen dokumenten und
nutzen unser veto denn das sogenannte
rechtsstaatsprinzip hat nichts mit
rechtsstaat zu tun sondern mit fast klar
wo genau rechtsstaat ist fast klar wo
letzte mal polen
naja ich weiß was in meinen aber es geht
um den haushalt für die nächsten sieben
jahre sondern ich liebe wie immer
nachgeben das hat sich doch bewährt
diesmal nicht ungarn und polen sind zu
weit gegangen und ich habe auch schon
die perfekte lösung das geht ratzfatz
ich zitiere artikel 50 satz eins aus dem
lissabonner vertrag
jeder mitgliedstaat kann beschließen aus
der union auszutreten also alle eu
länder außer polen und ungarn treffen
sich morgen in brüssel und beschließen
den austritt aus der union
eine minute später ist die eu offiziell
aufgelöst noch eine minute später
gründen alle länder außer polen und
ungarn eine neue union und die heißt eu
dbb die europäische union ohne die
bekloppten ungarn polen fertig da sparen
wir jedes jahr sagenhafte 17 milliarden
euro die polen und ungarn netto an eu
kohl kassieren 15 milliarden geben wir
direkt italien und spanien und vom rest
kaufen wir uns klar und schnecken oder
bereits pilze scheißegal alles besser
angelegt als für polen oder oder so und
jetzt schneide ich aus allen eu fanden
hier umhin zwei sterne raus sie dürfen
gerne zugucken
ja das ist mir zu aufregend carolin
kebekus
alter der club hatte er wieder alles
wahnsinn inhaltlich stark satire comedy
gruppe
ich habe es noch drauf also ich würde
den kanal direkt abonnieren und auf
gefällt mir drücken wenn ich das nicht
schon getan hätte das war wirklich stark
[Musik]